[Music]
thank you
the last Warriors thank you for joining
us at uh concluding press conference at
the extraordinary European Council
president you have the floor
foreign
rapid more
economics
and processes
the conclusions
coupling
flexibility
existence
authorizations foreign
foreign
energy
thank you Mr President Madam president
please yes good morning
um indeed I wanted to have a look at the
two topics that have been discussed this
afternoon and this night the discussion
on competitiveness in the European Union
is rooted first of all in a very wide
consensus we need to reach climate
neutrality by 2050 and we want the
European cleantech Industries to help us
get there
um we are very strong Advocates of Fair
competition also on the global stage
this is particularly true in the clean
tech sector and as I said we welcome
condition competition in this area in
fact we have a head start with the
cleantech industry we have an Innovative
and competitive industry we have a plan
that's our road map to 2050 fit for 55
and we have financial and policy support
with Next Generation EU so the setting
is good
now we need to preserve our Edge that's
the challenge right now on the
development the manufacture and rollout
of clean Technologies
and this especially against the backdrop
of the inflation reduction act as was
the main topic of the debate
I have presented two leaders our green
deal industrial plan
you know the main work strands the first
one is a regulatory environment that
incentivizes clean tech investment
the second is funding both through a
targeted and temporary flexibilization
of state aid and EU level funding
the aim of course of this investment is
to unleash also private capital
the third element is skills and finally
the fourth work Strand and active trade
policy to strengthen our supply chains
I know that the public debate focuses a
lot around state aid flexibility and EU
funding that's all right but I want to
emphasize that in fact all four strands
need to work hand in hand so we need a
stable and simple regulatory environment
if we want state aid and EO funding to
trigger Investments
and this also requires a
well-functioning European Capital Market
and likewise the speed to train new
qualified workers
is as important as the speed to issue
permissions
and access to necessary critical raw
materials is also a crucial point
to access and to finance as a crucial as
a point as to access a finance so the
overall picture has been discussed at
this Council the commission will now
table the concrete legal proposals
mid-march in time before the European
next march European Council
on migration
I think it is very important that the
European Council has clearly recognized
that migration is a European challenge
that requires a European response
we should keep in mind that this
European approach so working together is
27 allowed us to successfully for
example defeat the hybrid attack by
Belarus the weaponization of migrants
it also allowed us to welcome millions
and millions of Ukrainian refugees
fleeing Putin's bombs
so the lesson learned
in the past is we need to act together
when we do so
there is no challenge we cannot overcome
and I'm therefore glad that we agreed on
very concrete and operational steps
forward
there are two tracks to work strands the
one is the finalizing of the work on The
Pact on migration and Asylum that is key
so far we've made good progress and we
need to keep up the good Pace I count
now on the Swedish and the Spanish
presidency and of course on the European
Parliament what that is concerned
the second track was the main focus
tonight
it relates to operational measures we
can take now
the first one
borders must be managed
we will act to strengthen our external
borders and prevent irregular migration
and for that we will focus on two pilot
projects on borders
in other words we will provide an
integrated package of mobile and
stationary infrastructure from Cars to
cameras from watchtowers to electronic
surveillance
this requires EU funding it is welcome
bilateral funding and or bilateral
contributions and of course it also
requires national funding
and then we will launch pilot projects
that focus on Border procedures
in order to Showcase best practice so
registration
fast and fair Asylum procedures how to
deal with return
frontex and the EU Asylum agency and
europol will support these pilot
projects
furthermore furthermore concrete steps
the leaders agreed to mutually recognize
return decisions
this will allow to be faster with
returns the principle is if a return
decision is taken in one member State
it's valid in all member states so if
the person moves to another member State
you do not have to go through the same
procedure again the return decision is
valid
and leaders have also agreed to increase
the use of the safe country Concepts
this will pave the way towards a common
European list that is the goal and thus
a common European approach for increased
returns
and the third point is indeed unreturns
there we discussed how it is possible to
step up our engagement with key Partners
so the countries of origin
we are we agree that we need to speak
with one voice at the the European level
as one Europe that have different member
states different good relations to
countries of origin we should always use
the whole of Europe approach a holistic
approach
and we have many different incentives we
can use while recognizing the interests
of our partners for example to create
legal pathways
finally
while awaiting the adoption of the new
pact on migration and Asylum we need we
discuss that we need to better support
member states under pressure
so the voluntary solidarity mechanism
needs to deliver to ensure effective
solidarity and at the same time it is
important to address secondary movements
through the correct implementation of
the Dublin mechanism it is good that it
has been agreed in December there has
been agreement in December on a Dublin
Road map this should now be pushed
forward as soon and as fast as possible
thank you madam president
Jorge Valero your first please
um good night with Bloomberg a couple of
questions for both presidents first for
president Michelle uh you said that
leaders will come back discuss again the
proposal for the purchase of ammunition
in March so if you could tell us what
happened tonight why that decision was
wasn't taken today tonight it seems that
there were a couple of countries that
had some issues what were those issues
and also you could tell us a bit more
about the proposal what volumes are we
talking about how will be structure and
then for president Wonderland
during the previous press conference you
said that the export control export one
for the next package will will be worth
around 10 billion euros if I understood
well I mean this is quite a significant
amount if you could tell us a bit more
what sectors are you planning planning
to cover and also there was a very
specific proposal from president Celeste
at upstairs which was to sanction is
something that the commission is
seriously looking at and if so do you
think that you could overcome the
reluctance of some countries when it
comes to sanctioning rosatom thank you
for the first point and first question
the point of Estonia made the proposal
today when we started the meeting of the
European Council and that's because we
we felt that it was needed to have a
better preparation to fine-tune the way
we can make progress on that important
question but the good thing is the the
FED that in the meeting room in the
European Council we felt a broad support
on the principle who are together in a
more European way at least for the
member states who would decide to to
follow a certain approach in order to
cooperate with the industrial sector and
to make sure that we can speed up the
level of production of ammunition and
that we can also fulfill the the
commitments that are needed into and to
make sure that we we feel the Stars this
is uh the way we will work and we will
make sure that for the next European
currency with something more operational
than more concrete on the table
so what the sanctions question is
concerned we are right now in the
preparation so nothing is set in stone
therefore I cannot tell you any details
on the listing right now but on the 10
billion euros worth more or less the
sanctions package these is this is
targeted on Goods that are almost
Irreplaceable from somewhere else
and we look deep into the war Machinery
of Russia where we can
Define either Technologies or spare
parts that are being used by the
military complex but where we are able
because we are the unique provider to
ban the export on that a third thing we
do too is that the ukrainians when for
example shooting down Iranian drone are
analyzing in detail what the components
are and if there are components that we
see come from our regions for example
the European Union we make sure that
there's a clear ban on these components
too you see from my explanation it's
getting very very deep now very very
detailed but this is good and it is
important
um Sam please
thanks very much Sam flowing from the Ft
um could I ask one on the economy side
of things
um you mentioned the inflation reduction
act as the the key Focus uh when it
comes to foreign subsidies but in fact
obviously the subsidies uh in China uh
for the the green technologies are
extremely considerable allegedly
distortionary as well that was that
discussed today in any depth the Chinese
angle here at the at the summit and
where do you see the key responses being
here is it amount of trade defenses the
foreign subsidies rules or is it a more
to do with again state aid
flexibilization and on state aid
flexibilization specifically uh one of
the more controversial issues is the
idea of matching Clauses did you sense
any sign of a consensus as to whether
member states are interested in going
down that route thank you
now from me just just a few a few words
first
um we want to address a global
competitiveness of the European Union in
the short term but also in the mid and
the only term is one first element this
is the IRA it is bother than that
because we are writing not only uh
United States and we have for many years
sales difficulties with country like
China in terms of needs for us to
rebalance the relationships with uh with
them but there are also other examples
of countries in the world
0.1.2 this was very important to take
decisions to make decisions today in the
follow-up of the last meeting we had in
December knowing that there is a process
because in December we decided to test
the commission the transmission
automation made the communication and
and today we gave additional impetus
based on the pillar that the
transmission myself with explained to
you and we want to be pragmatic it means
that we are using the the means that are
available it means that we need to adapt
to state-aid regime but you want to make
it in a way that make sure that we
defend the Integrity of digital Market
point one and that we are taking 200
Global competitiveness this one one
thing and on the other hand there are
existing means there are EU fundings and
want to make it more flexible but it
means that for the next European Council
we count on the commission based on the
conclusions we have agreed on today in
order to take further steps and to
implement the legislative and the and
and and all the all the rules that that
will be needed to to apply for some of
them it depends only on the permission
for some of them we need we need some
some legal implementations this is how
we intend to work and if we take into
account the magnitude of what can be
done when the member states
through the adaptation stated regime in
addition the flexibility of the EU
existing funding this is a lot of money
that can be mobilized in the short term
and they can be targeted on the
Strategic sectors in order to make sure
that we defend the single market and
that we defend the economic basis of the
European Union
so
to your first the first part of your
question what China is concerned if you
look at the inflation reduction Act
it is transparent open
369 billion dollars we know about it and
clearly defined and targeted so we know
exactly what sectors six sectors of the
clean tech what sectors can benefit from
it and therefore it's for us also very
open and transparent to deal with it
but China is concerned we know that they
are giving massive subsidies not only on
the cleantech sector but in general
so it's a much broader in transparent
it's hidden subsidies in transparent
approach
we know that our companies have often
problems to have access to the Chinese
market
and that there's non-respect of Ip
rights so the topic is much wider
than our focus on the inflation
reduction act therefore also we are
developing a much broader strategy to
deal with that you know that we have
developed
instruments to
um to to counter
these elements that I've just the
Chinese behavior and this is something
which we have to keep an eye on what the
clean tech sector is concerned without
any doubt but the the subject is broader
than only the cleantech sector what the
matching Clauses are concerned in the
state aid no we have not discussed that
in detail because the public
consultation is still ongoing and it is
necessary for the leaders that then the
proposal is uh on the table now it's the
time for the public consultation and uh
the feedback is then in detail on
questions like the matching clause for
example
uh
applications
so um what we have agreed on is that we
need for the Border
protection the approach of as I said an
integrated package and there are three
sources of funding national funding
you're free to do of course with the
national funding what you deem necessary
bilateral contributions are welcomed I
think also in the solidarity mechanism
this is one option to give a bilateral
Financial contribution and then the EU
funding and as I've said we're very
clear on the management of the Border
one of the pilot we are aiming at for
example has an existing fence but
nothing else
and it doesn't function
so what is necessary and this is clear
you need the cameras you need the
electronic surveillance you need roads
along the fence for patrols for example
you need the equip Personnel you need
watchtowers you need vehicles
so all these topics are should be in an
integrated package the focus is on
having a functioning border that we know
if somebody comes to the Border there is
a procedure that should be the same all
over the European external borders and
the Pilot's goal is also to Showcase
that we can have these proper procedures
functioning at a border
um on Dublin
oh I forgot the content it's too early
in the morning
um
so um it is important the Dublin roadmap
is just agreed in December
by the ministers and they have to work
on it and implement it so it is
absolutely important uh to to follow up
now the Dublin roadmap but
um we have also agreed that we will
report
um at the next update at the next
European Council on progress that is
made on the different proposals that we
have made in the conclusions or that are
summarized in the conclusions
foreign
Productions
[Music]
thank you madam president Mr President
see you again soon in March at our
formal European Council thanks a lot